in a sleepy Hamburg suburb a small
glimpse into Germany's War Machine this
plant makes parts for heavy weapons
including the in-demand leopard 2 tank
but while President Putin said he's
scaling up his arms production here they
warn Germany hasn't been doing the same
for me it is worrying that Germany is
donating 14 leopards two tanks to
Ukraine and has not reordered a single
one Germany is one of the biggest donors
to Ukraine last year it also announced a
hundred billion Euro fund to boost its
own military but making weapons takes
time if I ordered a leper 2 tank today
how long before one could be delivered
it will last between 12 months and 24
months in the meantime it's feared
Germany's leaving itself exposed
well it's weakened on a daily level that
is I think clear
we have not only given away leopard two
tanks we also have given away the big
who with us we have given away German
Iris tea Rockets to the Ukraine air
defense
Army so we are bledding out if you so
want how serious is this for defense of
the country
as long as the conflict stays in the
Ukraine
there is time but who can control that
for decades really since the end of the
Cold War Germany's military has
traditionally been underfunded and
Putin's Invasion has presented
authorities here with two big challenges
firstly they have to keep supplying
Ukraine but then there's also the
mammoth task of upgrading their own
military
the defense ministers pledged to invest
on both fronts and wants more cash for
arms a Ministry spokesman told me as
part of NATO Germany would never have to
defend itself solo but the war in
Ukraine is draining allies supplies too
the German Ministry of defense is
plainly wrong on this because yes
Germany is in NATO but in a way Germany
is NATO and NATO NATO's armed forces or
NATO's military strength is the strength
of its member states and so if member
states do not have the military forces
required that NATO NATO is weak
depleted before the war broke out
Germany's military is now in an even
worse shape an urgent problem requiring
urgent action Siobhan Robbins Sky News
hamper